[Musique]
1400 un peu rue legendre un édifice
plutôt anonyme en plein coeur de
montréal mais attention ici il se passe
des choses pas du tout banni on est dans
un endroit industrielle il ya beaucoup
de bruit beaucoup de camions ont très
peu de végétation c'est vraiment une île
haute chaleur mais quand on rentre à
l'intérieur vous allez voir un îlot de
fraîcheur et pour rentrer mais vous
c'est nous louise et nos métiers est une
des nombreux entrepreneurs scientifiques
chercheurs productrice de la centrale
agricole pour lui un peu dans notre
horreur fame
la fente à un espace urbain d'innovation
et d'expérimentation en alimentation axé
sur l'économie circulaire toutes les
entreprises qui cohabite avec nous on
l'a pas fait sur le main pour expliquer
les missions offert des champignons 80
nyon des champignons du cidre des vignes
un potager une pisciculture et beaucoup
de ténébrions tout ça à un seul et même
endroit ici ça circule fait des plans de
quoi ce
bordel bonne récolte veut pas voir
c'est ici que ça se passe mais auprès du
mapaq on était même terme comme les
autres producteurs agricoles sauf que
nous on est en ville et notre bétail
c'est du micro bêta et puis vie empilés
les uns sur les autres un auteur
confirmant aux vaches qui ont les pieds
apatow est risquée qui est une
entreprise d'élevage d'insectes en
économie circulaire est un des quatre
membres cofondateur de la centrale
agricole c'est une coopérative qui
étaient fondées donc en 2019 et qui ne
cesse de croître depuis mais ça ça sent
la fin on fasse un peu le vrai nom ici
tout le monde est interrelié il produit
en y connut circulable petite leçon
l'économie linéaire celle qu'on connaît
bien ces experts fabriquer consommer et
jeter l'économie circulaire c'est une
boucle l'énergie et des matières
premières sont réutilisées tout au long
du cycle
la ferme si on produit environ 8 tonnes
par an de l'essec fait deux fois que
votre déshydraté ce qui en termes de
déchets en fait ce qui est intéressant
c'est presque zéro déchet les insectes
sont nourris avec des résidus
alimentaires qui deviendront des
protéines comestibles et du fumier pour
le potager expérimental
on a eu une grosse récolte des
betteraves
on a eu des fatidiques l'écart est
dieppois revers aussi et aujourd'hui
d'enfants ont accueilli de match on y
vit haricots blancs ont fait une
expérience comparative entre rfi minesec
léfini turquie le compost est réduit
pour être appelé tapir des tendances et
par rapport à tout ce qu'elle quitte en
créant des six qui et c'est quoi la
biomasse des sages
[Musique]
véronique de vigneault vire on est au
cinquième vignoble deviner en ville
projets de recherche qui vise à étudier
le comportement des vignes en milieu
urbain le vignoble devine en ville de la
centrale agricole et le plus grand au
monde sur un toit le terreau de ce
vignoble est particulier et très
innovant en fait c'est une première dans
le monde on a décidé de lancer un
nouveau protocole de recherche ici qui
va étudier la dégradation du vert dans
les échos le sable est une ressource
naturelle non renouvelable
donc on voulait vraiment éviter
d'utiliser le savent donc ici le renvoi
il remplace le sable pourquoi on
l'associait l'économie circulaire celui
de l'homme nous on a une boucle qui
magnifique parce qu'on voit du vin eau
mais la bouteille de vin dans le bac à
recyclage la collecte sélective prend
possession de ces bouteilles là ça
arrive un centre de tri comme prix
centriste le bois le verre et il nous
renvoie le verts broyés que l'on intègre
à notre témoin dans lequel on fait
encore une fois pousser de la vigne et
éventuellement en fait ouais donc là
hellip entière comme effet que vous
publiez ce jusqu'au bois ça bouge sur le
toit ça bouge aussi au sous sol de la
centrale la synergie et bill présente
est plutôt surprenante
opercules et la première difficulté
urbaine au québec
onze grands bassins ont été installées
pour accueillir les premiers jeux dès le
mois de décembre est ce assez réaliste
d'élever des poissons comme ça dans un
sous-sol industriel oui tout à fait vous
allez à la pêche ça va prendre au moins
un an à partir du monde auront donc en
novembre 2008 de l on va commencer à
pouvoir pêcher les premiers poissons ya
comme un intérêt à faire de la recherche
avec tricycle qui produit des insectes
donc après remplace une partie de la
mouiller avec le vin c'est entre 25 et
30 tonnes d'omble chevalier seront
produits chaque année comme en économie
circulaire ne rejette rien voici deux
voisins qui vont bien sont en
[Musique]
jeu froid et de champignons maison nous
on a besoin d'un environnement avec un
art extrêmement humide puis ap recul je
n'ai rares plein d'humilité grâce à ses
beau bassin ils ont besoin d'un frêne ou
si c'est comme ça huawei c'est délicieux
ces diplomates rose toi ici on a déploré
delorme che froisser les spécialistes il
passionné des champignons si je peux
parler tout le temps de champignons
parce qu'ils ont toujours quelque chose
à offrir mais aussi cette année là où
ils permettent de boucler des boucles
noires vertueuse pour geoffroy les
champignons ne vont pas que dans
l'assiette il travaille même à
transformer des matières organiques en
matériaux de construction et c'est ça on
économise ce clara toujours on dit les
déchets c'est seulement des ressources
abandonné ça c'est du café puis du bois
on peut donc qu'ils ont mais la culture
lui veulent ont remis il a
une série de réactions biochimiques ils
vont faire un objet solide si on a
quelque chose qui peut remplacer le
styromousse qui est fait à partir de
déchets qui conte pasteur qui
compostaient le bloc de culture pour
l'année dont le compresser on est
nombreux lacs ici qui est l'équivalent
de le rêve de geffroy srec
éventuellement les kiosques dans les
marchés où seront vendus les produits de
la centrale soit fabriqué à partir de
ces champignons
l'économie circulaire à la centrale
serait aussi une économie de proximité à
la cidrerie sauvage on embrasse des
cidre de pomme et de petits fruits non
utilisés cueillies dans la région
on s'est dit que ça faisait beaucoup de
sens d'avoir un local en ville à
montréal on a un verger qui est dans le
grand montréal et puis en fait de créer
aussi des synergies avec tous les
membres qui sont présents
lana pouvoir y goûter moi oui c'est ça
donc là c'est un assemblage avec pommes
poires mais ça sent vraiment très bon
c'est pas très sympa très sucré on a un
petit peu d'amertume et c'est vrai que
la majorité des cidres qu'on fait on
vraiment peu de sucre on va vraiment
plutôt être sur la fraîcheur un peu
l'acidité et ouais c'est ça de la pomme
c'est qu'on est moins utile
dans ce contexte d'économie circulaire
surtout d'économie circulaire de
proximité on voit si de fermer les
boucles en minimisant les transports en
minimisant le gaspillage des ressources
vers les coups de dégustations de vins
et on avait un report qui a été gré des
aliments de toutes les entreprises là il
y avait des champignons qui côtoyait
mais insectes je pense dans débouché il
y avait un beau poisson avait été mis en
valeur à l'heure du lunch on se
rassemble ils ce sont les idées qui se
mettent à circuler envisager des
synergies avec la lie du vin pour
pouvoir faire évoluer nos cidre ça c'est
des choses qui nous intéresse la
centrale agricole est en train de
coloniser l'édifice entier pour devenir
la plus grande coopérative agricole
urbaine au monde